la sucesión geométrica adn está definida
por la siguiente fórmula y bueno aquí
tenemos que el primer término a de 1 es
igual a menos 1 octavo y cada término
después de éste queda definido de la
siguiente manera adn será igual a 2 por
el término anterior al término n
entonces 2 por adn
1 entonces bueno la pregunta es que es a
de 4 el cuarto término de la sucesión
así que bueno como siempre te invito a
que pongas pausa el vídeo y que lo
intentes intenta averiguar que esa de
cuatro el cuarto término de la sucesión
geométrica que tenemos aquí muy bien
entonces iniciemos vamos a resolver esto
hay varias maneras de resolverlo bueno
una de ellas es simplemente usar estas
fórmulas directamente entonces podemos
decir que a de 4 será igual en este caso
a de 4 será igual a 2
ad3 ya de 3 usando nuevamente la fórmula
tenemos que hacer 3 es igual a 2 por ade
2 cada término es igual a 2 por el
término anterior y luego regresamos a la
fórmula tenemos que a de 2 es igual a 2
por a de 1 y bueno por suerte ya sabemos
que esa de uno a de uno es menos un
octavo entonces tenemos dos x
menos un octavo que es igual a menos un
cuarto así que esto es menos un cuarto
entonces 2 x menos un cuarto es igual a
menos dos cuartos que es igual a menos
un medio entonces a de 4 es igual a 2 x
3 y ya de 3 es igual a menos un medio
entonces 2 x menos un medio eso es igual
a menos 1 y bueno ahí tendrías una
manera de resolver esto esa es una
hagamos hagámoslo de otra manera ahora
otra manera de pensar esto es bueno aquí
tenemos el término inicial y también
conocemos nuestra razón común sabemos
que cada término sucesivo es 2 por el
término anterior entonces podríamos
escribir explícitamente esto dado que es
una definición recursiva para nuestra
asociación geométrica podemos escribir
explícitamente
adn es igual al término inicial menos un
octavo y lo multiplicamos por 2 elevado
a la n 1 ahora comprobemos que esto
tiene sentido entonces a de uno es menos
un octavo basándome en esta fórmula por
2 a la 1 menos uno que es 2 a la 0 y
bueno podemos ver que tiene sentido
porque eso es igual a menos un octavo
basándonos en esta fórmula entonces a de
2 sería menos un octavo por 2 a la 2 - 1
entonces tenemos menos un octavo por 2 a
la 1 entonces tenemos nuestro término
inicial y lo multiplicamos por 2 a la 1
que es exactamente a de 2 es menos un
cuarto y si queremos encontrar el cuarto
término de la sucesión geométrica
podemos simplemente usando esta fórmula
tenemos que a de cuatro es igual a menos
un octavo por dos a las cuatro menos uno
entonces a de 4 es igual a menos 1
octavo por 2 al cubo y entonces tenemos
que menos un octavo por 8 eso es menos 1
y bueno tal vez estés en duda de cuál
método usar pero con este método este
segundo que hicimos donde sacamos una
fórmula explícitamente dado que
conocemos el primer término el término
inicial y la razón común entonces bueno
aquí con este método resulta bastante
fácil porque porque bueno por ejemplo si
tú quisieras conocer el término no se
digamos 40 o 50 o 1000 con el método
recursivo tardaríamos muchísimo en
averiguarlo y nos tardaríamos bueno
mucho tiempo y gastaría mucho papel ajá
pero con esto sale fácil